damn it
i was wrong
i can't see [ __ ]
i really thought it would work
you were [ __ ] duped
oh well um
at least it's peaceful
yep
that's why i come here when i'm pissed
off
so a lot believe me
look
hayden they're back on
[Music]
they're [ __ ] coming back on
[Music]
did you see that
you see that
it's beautiful oh i can't believe it
no i just can't believe
[Music]
oh i see it daniel i'm at a lookout
point and it's quite the show
how's this happen dark as hell for 15
years and suddenly this
i don't know don't know
but we need to find out then drop by the
campaign and let's talk been missing you
like last year's snowboarder
while shotgunning beers and screwing
bartenders you know me it's a
gift we'll meet you there dumbass
something's wrong
no
no no no no no
no
[ __ ]
what the hell's going on
so that's the fisheye how do we get
there
the fish eyes gotta wait we gotta wait
but why
we need to check the substations ones
over there level with the pk tower what
about the fish eye listen i want to help
you and i will help we'll do this
together
[Music]
but you have to understand it's the
first
it's been the same situation for over 10
years
10 years of this [ __ ] darkness we
gotta check this out how do we get to
the substation
it's an old power glider it'll help you
get to places you normally can't reach
just follow me
wait
[ __ ]
this paraglider can it be made to fly
faster
possibly
all right let's go
it used to be a night runner's favorite
toy you're a night runner
me night runner
i wish
ugh
[Music]
uh
hey you
seen any signs of renegades around here
no
see private now calm down and let aglot
sink
what's there to think about why not head
back to base
who the heck are you anyway
i'm someone offering to help
i'll check what happened to the power
you know anything else about it that's
top secret military information we're
trying to figure out how to get up there
just go ahead and tell them everything
why don't you every last detail
but what's the big secret huh
we need to get this piece of [ __ ]
working that's what
my colleagues vastly oversimplifying
things but his just is correct
there are obvious signs of the
electricity having returned and this
here appears to be a substation
it and others like it are capable of
transmitting electricity throughout the
city
we have orders to get this building
functioning once more
meaning turn it back on
unfortunately without climbing equipment
access to it is severely limited
i can climb up there without the
equipment you'd be willing to do that
you'd be doing a great favor for the
peacekeeper
uniform
what was that he said i think it was
something about his mother
and a goat
pk morons
we'll be taking that electricity thank
you very much
kill em
i would surmise the main circuit
suffered a break
find a cable and connect the source of
power to the transmitter that should
restore the circuit
yep i'm on top of the substation trying
to connect the power to the transmitter
i wasn't a piece of cake in here after
all
i met a bunch of pks who couldn't get to
the substation themselves
so that's why you haven't called me yet
you should see them
decide which one i like more
you know that'll cost you right
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so you did it
are you pissed at me
your choice and i know why
but if it were me
i'm for the free folk all the way
i don't understand there are a lot more
substations i guess
can we first go to the fisheye
let's meet in the canteen
i'll wait for you there
diarrhea you're on your own friend
take my advice
leave this city
[Music]
frank is one handsome fella
it's a shame he's such a booze
well
[Music]
hank
they slaughtered us one by one like
[ __ ] rabbits frank
frank it's me wake up you
what the [ __ ] you doing here
you know romney my conversation with
robin's been dead for years frank pull
yourself together
you gotta visit her
who's that
queen of [ __ ] england
i gotta act old danny now this is aiden
he has a gre access key waltz used it to
turn on the electricity in town
working gre key you're full of [ __ ]
show it him
where'd you get it
from one of walt's men so you want it
once it's meant to hey easy frank aiden
is on our side we think this contains
data proving what they did to us in the
hospital
so you still believe you'll find out why
walt's [ __ ] up your childhood
okay
i'll tell you ready
yeah because he's a [ __ ] psycho he's
[ __ ] in the head that's your holy
grail and arc of the covenant all in one
load happy
hayden right
you and luang can get the [ __ ] out of my
face now
you hear that
[ __ ] something's happening
will you check
i'm right behind you
i'm sure
i've seen them
renegade to the central loop
nonsense to all units renegades are in
the central loop i repeat renegades are
in the center they're surrounding the
fisheye
can anyone hear me over
[Applause]
[ __ ]
find the stage
to the um
ate it one more hit'll destroy
ugh
[Applause]
[Music]
on the forward left
[Music]
uh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
now
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
they
one move and he died
david
you